blake wharton lumière assez intéressant
c'est l'ex alors bien le soleil un peu
où l'on regarde ce qui brouille la
pourquoi ça brûle caps n'a jamais
vraiment des vrais foulard à droite là
dans un bol bien c'est quoi c'est de
l'accidentel ou séduit à temps passons à
côté ça puis on ira déjà depuis dix ans
je dis je sais qu'ils sont là bas mais
là ça je dis rien là un effet devient
bien abattant à sa collègue passe ou
attendent à un bon
d'ailleurs pas accidentel ou pas a non
il ya un mec qui fait de l'état on est
en bas quoi et avec qui essaye de
l'éteindre avec eux deux mais bon non
non non par exemple accidentelle c'est
un verbe gravité on le tue la riots
lolli bien-être c'est pas mal de ses
pouvoirs
baird co star parce qu en visite hier le
attend regardez moi le vrai pouvoir
reprendre de l'art baroque perdrait sa
poule cadre au ca
loli solide solidaire
ok on va travailler on essaye d'être de
travailler sur les sur les collines
embrasse large